Everything I could avoid saying like, I
love you. I said it. Thank you. Yes. You,
you know what you know,
you know.
Oh, okay. Yeah,
I am Trey Baxter and I am 24 years old.
I'm clean a Cordova and I'm 21,
10 years.
Woo.
We're on top of things.
Wow. I can't hear anything. Yeah,
she's grooving.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know what story she'll tell you,
but uh,
we actually met on Tinder.
Funny enough. I know, I know.
And uh, sure enough, I get a message,
I get a match and it's this just
gorgeous girl. I'm, when she said, Hey,
do you want to just like go get a pizza?
I know an awesome Italian restaurant.
And I was just like,
yeah,
I do want to get pizza and go to
an Italian restaurant with you.
So that same night, um, just a couple
of hours later, I told my friends like,
they were like,
yeah,
hey dude. Hey Dude, you want to hang
out? And I'm like, no, I have date.
Can't hear you. You're
good. You can take them off.
So my friend had come over that
evening and made me a Tinder account.
Um, I had one for one night and,
and I met him. It was like, well,
he's very attractive. I'd like to talk
to him. And then I asked him to go meet,
meet at this like Italian restaurant that
I pretended to know it closed like in
a half an hour.
And we didn't want the date to end.
So we went to another place that
was open for another hour. Um,
and then that closed and we
still wanted to hang out.
So we went to another place
that was open 24 hours.
So we had all the time in the world.
First thing I noticed was her eyes,
like her eyes popped out.
She just was so gorgeous.
I couldn't help but stare at her.
My first impression was that he,
he had so much like enthusiasm.
I got there five minutes late. I don't
know why, but I was like, I'm so sorry.
Wait, hey. Oh my God, I'm so
sorry. I'm two minutes late. Like,
I don't like being late. I
really don't like that. But yeah,
I just remember you were like bolting,
apologizing.
I'm so sorry I'm late. I
was like, it's okay, please.
When I realized she was different,
I wanted to date this person was,
she was going on a week long vacation.
I prepared myself.
I was just like, okay, she's going
to be gone. So just let her go.
Don't message her.
Don't be annoying.
And so that whole entire time I
could not stop thinking about her.
Towards the end of her vacation,
she's messaged me. It's really weird.
I miss you after just hanging
out with her four days in a row,
she's sent me that message. I was
just like, okay, that means something.
I think
the hardest, biggest one for me
was when we first started dating.
Um, cause she's very goal oriented and
uh, she's very much about her career.
She thought at first that being in a
relationship would be kind of hard and
distract her from it.
And so she just kind of needed to take
time for herself to focus on herself and
her life and what she wanted.
She wanted to keep talking to me in
this time that we were broken up,
prevent mother too.
And she kept calling me and put me in a
very confused state and I started to get
really upset.
Yeah.
I think the biggest one was a total
game changer for me because it made me
realize how much I wanted to be with him.
But I remember how I felt during
this fight and he left. Um,
I stayed in the apartment and I was
going crazy because he shut his phone off
and I couldn't talk to him and I had
no idea and I had stayed up that whole
night.
I'm waiting for him to come home and uh,
and he did and he came home with coffee.
I didn't want to say anything.
I just wanted to apologize.
Um,
and that was, that was, I
think the biggest fight.
Your ears are sweating
me. I said that. Let me first.
Okay. This is how I said, I said,
I literally said hypothetically,
if I said I love you,
how would you feel?
Ah,
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
He is extremely romantic.
He's like one of those
hopelessly romantic kind of guys.
And I was and still am,
the garlic doesn't like cheesy thing.
We relying on his car and you said,
I love you.
And I remember saying like, it's just
a blur of words kind of saying like,
thank you. Like everything I could avoid
saying like, I love you. I said it.
Thank you. Yes. You, you
know what you know, you know,
I was not ready or I wasn't sure.
I didn't know what the I
love you could bring up out.
So I just kept it at,
you know,
mmm.
I chose you because it just felt right.
It felt like a,
it felt like it was very much supposed
to happen. And uh, I have never felt,
um,
happiness like I do with you.
Okay.
I just,
I have never ever been happier.
I know it's because he,
I feel like it's just such a
rare person to come across.
Um, in general, just in your life.
I think out of, out of everyone,
uh,
I just like,
I love being with him
because it's trendy and,
um,
and I think that like,
he keeps me
like just loving life all the time.
I've grown up massively, uh,
after meeting her because of her,
if she snapped me out of a lot of things.
And so I have a grown up
massively matured hell of a lot.
Um, and I would not be that mature
or growing up if I had not met her.
No. I told her everything and
literally tell her everything.
Yes.
Go ahead.
No,
I don't think there's anything
that we haven't talked about.
Do you have anything? No. Nope.
That'd be safe.
Okay.
Thank you. Very nice. Thank you,
man. That was fun. Good. Whoa.